hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
and i see all kinds of questions here
saved up so let's see one here
from arcatec
uh
does evolution move towards complexity
or simplicity
interesting question
so first of all what are we talking
about here we're talking about
uh presumably biological evolution
and we're talking about the
progression of species
that uh we can see for example in the
fossil record we go back you know 65
million years and we start seeing
dinosaur fossils we go back a bit more
we see trilobite fossils we go back even
further we see fossils of other kinds of
organisms
until i think the oldest fossils might
be about two billion years old uh maybe
a little bit more than that maybe 2.5
billion years which are mostly all
single-celled organisms and so on
and
so
there's sort of this
this appearance in the fossil record
that over the course of time the
organisms that have populated the earth
have gotten more complicated and we look
at ourselves and we say gosh we've got
all this complicated stuff in us humans
and uh
you know we're the we're the uh the
finest production of the process of
evolution so we might think
so but the question is is this really a
thing that that things get more
complicated over time you know charles
darwin who originally developed this
theory of evolution by natural selection
thought that it was
i mean in uh so so the you know the the
big idea of evolution is
organisms
have
uh you know have descendants they have
their children organisms and so on um
and um
at every generation there are random
mutations random changes in what we now
assume is mostly the genetics of the
organism there are probably some other
aspects of the organism that sort of get
carried along from from the parent
organism to the child organism that
aren't quite just what's in the pure
dna code of the organism but it's
roughly things getting passed from
parents to children
and
that every time every time you go from
parents to children there's a certain
kind of random change that can happen
and the whole point of evolution by
natural selection is
if you're a critter whose random change
is beneficial so you have a
you know a better life and then you're
able to have more children
then that change then then you will tend
to pass that change to your children and
there'll be more of them so they have a
chance to pass it to more children and
gradually whatever changes were a good
idea
end up winning out and all the organisms
end up getting that change and the
things that were a bad idea those
organisms had fewer children and the
changes that they had will tend to die
out that's kind of the theory of natural
selection
of evolution by natural selection one of
the things that's been mysterious is
there clearly are big changes from
the trilobites or something to us humans
big changes but from from one of those
to the other and the question is how did
those big changes really happen
and people have seen
evidence in in actual examples in field
biology of evolution in action
so you know they're famous examples of i
don't know there's a kind of moth for
example
that uh in places where there was no
grimy industrial pollution the moth was
was quite white and that was a good
color for it because the things that it
had to
land on and camouflage itself around
were also quite white but when there was
grimy industrial pollution it was a sort
of a darker color and the moths that
were that
for random in their random mutations the
moths that were darker colors ended up
being more successful less likely to be
eaten um and more children moths
and so the the darker color won out and
there are many examples of that that
have been sort of seen
in uh in an actual sort of practical uh
observation of the operation of natural
of evolution by natural selection now
in
in higher organisms like moths and
mammals and things like that
it's it's a little bit hard to see that
evolution in action
in microorganisms things like bacteria
viruses you can see that evolution much
more easily and so for example
in
uh well sort of
in in the pandemic for example we've
seen all kinds of evolution in the virus
um responding to oh it's blocked from
being this way because i don't know
there's a vaccine that's that's causing
people to not get sick of the virus as
that form or if the virus changes a bit
then the virus can be more successful
for the virus
and managed to get past on more and so
on and so that will be the variant that
wins out you see the same thing at a
more microscopic level if you have
bacteria for example
and you're growing them
people grow bacteria on you know plates
and so on they give them kind of sugar
type solution that they consume and the
bacteria will just replicate their more
and more bacteria
the thing that's sort of real bad for
bacteria is antibiotics antibiotic drugs
kill bacteria
um and they do it by a variety of
different mechanisms and so one thing
you could do is on a kind of a plate
where you're where you have these
bacteria grow and you put some
antibiotic on it and you see that at
first all the bacteria could sort of get
to where the antibiotic is they just die
out
but then gradually as the more and more
bacteria replicate and bacteria
replicates i don't know how long it
takes maybe maybe half an hour for a
bacterium to make child bacteria so to
speak
um that
so they're replicating much quite
quickly and there are lots and lots of
sort of uh different variants of the
bacteria that get produced and maybe one
of them is successful at getting through
the antibiotic and then that one wins
out and then many many more copies of it
and so on then maybe you put some more
antibiotic different kind of antibiotic
on this plate and you'll see the same
thing happen again so you can see this
process of evolution happen
in a very direct way
in in something like you know plates
with bacteria on them you can literally
see you know in different colors of
bacteria you can see that oh yes this
kind of color uh i don't know exactly
whether they're real colors or whether
they're only colors that can be seen
under a microscope with them
with particular ways of treating light
but um
in any case you kind of see
evolution really in action
as the bacteria kind of folks learn
um to
modify themselves to avoid um the the
antibiotic when i say modify themselves
i mean
they're
that's not really what happens what
really happens is one bacterium has a
child bacterium which has a child
bacterium and so on and at every stage
there is a random mutation and of the i
don't know
uh you know let's say there were 10
child bacteria produced
one of them is more successful than the
others because for example it doesn't
get killed off by the antibiotic and
then that's the one that gets to
replicate and have its children and so
the traits that it has which let it
survive the antibiotic get passed to its
children that keeps going from there
so so we've seen lots of examples now of
sort of biological evolution by natural
selection and effect in action
um the question is does natural
selection
lead inevitably to the production of
more and more complex organisms
and and famously charles darwin
uh sort of assumed that it did
and even the very last sentence of his
origin of species book from uh 1859 or
so um was uh
uh it's some
uh it its last sentence was something
like
just as the earth
is keeps on circling around the sun
according to the fixed law of gravity so
in other words that's a sort of physical
inevitability that the earth is going to
keep circling around the sun according
to this law of gravity so
he assumed uh organisms he didn't quite
say more complex but kind of implied
that progressively more complex
organisms our being and will continue to
evolve through natural selection in the
future so he thought that there might be
some fundamental natural law that says
that over the course of biological
evolution you would um uh
uh you would have um uh progressively
more complex organisms produced
nobody ever managed to figure that out
it's not something we really know
happens
um in
it's there are sort of toy models of
evolution where things a bit like that
happen but it's not totally convincing
and sometimes sort of the bad case for
us proud complex organisms on earth
is you know maybe there's actually a
really simple organism it's a virus
maybe it's something else which can just
tear its way through all of the complex
life on earth and be the most successful
organism and take over the planet we
don't know that that's not the case now
let's hope it's not the case for for our
species so to speak but we don't know
that's not the case that the most
successful organism won't actually be a
pretty simple organism
i remember uh you know when people are
doing these um
oh
you know you make i don't know whether
there's battle bots or something like
that you know these these things you
make out of lego you make out of other
kinds of things you kind of have your
little you know lego car and you're
trying to bash it into other lego cars
and and have you know see who who wins
so to speak uh it is not always the case
that the most complex design is the one
that wins sometimes it's a simpler
design that wins and we don't really
know that that isn't the case for
biology
now what tends to happen in biology is a
little bit like what happens in
technology which is that you'll have
there are ideas there are sort of new
innovations like you know the trilobites
had the innovative idea of having eyes
that could detect light other organisms
had you know innovative ideas like
living on the land or doing
photosynthesis those kinds of things
what happens is over the course of
biological evolution a new idea will
show up
something some some new way of doing
things will show up
and particularly at the beginning it's
often a huge win like when plants first
came on the land in the bubbanephras
period huge wind tons of plants all over
the planet that's what led us to you
know a bunch of fossil fuel deposits
from that period of time because there
was so much plant life there was sort of
no competition and it was just the thing
that covered the planet
and and then gradually well that idea
gets you know there are other ideas that
come in and so on but this notion of
over the course of time eventually some
new idea comes in and then sort of
biological evolution rides that idea for
a while that's a pretty common thing to
see and so one of the things that you
see in in by now in biological evolution
is we are the composite of many ideas
some of them are good ideas some of them
might not be such good ideas
what you also quite often see in the
fossil record is for example let's say
trilobites
um they were a very successful
collection of organisms and they lasted
i know hundreds of millions of years i
think um all together um and you know
the first ones look kind of simple and
then they get more ornate and they've
got these little sort of
you know antennas hanging out and
they've got more complicated leg
patterns and segments and things they
get more and more complicated they get
all kinds of not quite hair but all
kinds of detailed stuff on them and then
in the later stages of tidal bites they
actually get simpler again
and you see that quite often with
technology people say well we've just
first of all managed to get i don't know
a graffiti user interface to work on a
computer it'll be pretty simple or the
early computer game is pretty simple
and um and then people say look we can
add all this stuff and look we've got
this feature and that feature and the
other feature and then it gets much more
complicated and then often in the end
people realize what's important and
what's not and it gets simpler again and
the same thing happens in biological
evolution that the
all of those elaborate feathery things
on the trilobites turned out it didn't
matter and turned out producing those
feathery things well who knows maybe
they could get tangled up in some plant
or some such other thing and it was
actually a lose for the trilobite just
as you know you make a more complicated
user interface well maybe the users get
confused and they stop buying your
product
and uh you'd be better off having fewer
features fewer buttons on your user
interface that will actually be a more
fit user interface so to speak
so that that that kind of thing happens
now there's sort of a question
of you know is there a force towards
sort of adding more innovations in
biological organisms to make things sort
of more complicated there are many
things that are quite mysterious still
in biology for example
why is it that there are as many
organisms as there are we don't know
exactly how many but they're probably
close to 10 million different species on
the earth why so many
there's a law that that uh sometimes
claimed i think it may be somewhat
accurate but if you have an island that
the number of species on the island is
somehow proportional to the size of the
island according to some power law
formula
um
but you know and that that sort of the
bigger island allows more stuff to go on
and there are more different species but
why should there be more species why is
it just that there's a successful
species and it's the winner
well that's a complicated question it's
a complicated question for an individual
species it's also a complicated question
for groups of species
by the time you're dealing with groups
of species you have to think about sort
of who eats who and how these different
species interact with each other i mean
the most common issue is food webs of uh
you know basically one organism eats the
big the smaller organism and so on or
eats other organisms and there's this
sort of gradual there's this sort of
chain of trophic levels of who eats who
and like i think on the land there are a
limited number like four or five trophic
levels in the ocean they're like 20 or
something often and it's kind of in the
the bigger fish theory there's always
you know the little tiny plankton and
they're eaten by the bigger thing and
the bigger thing and the bigger thing
eventually there's always a bigger fish
type type theory of how things work and
that leads to this pretty complicated
set of interdependencies between the
different species in the ocean for
example
and i think so that that's that's at the
level of inter-species interactions
at the level of an individual species
the question is sort of uh
you know what why should there be many
different species why should there be
uh uh sort of uh why is it the case that
we don't see on the surface of the earth
we see some species that are pretty
widely spread uh across the whole
surface of the earth and we see others
that are just in specific places you
know we see the marsupials in australia
why aren't there my stupids in other
places
why uh why do we see you know particular
kinds of plants in particular areas
sometimes a particular plant will be
particularly adapted to
live in the rainforest in some in some
different kind of environment or some
animal will be you know it's it's kind
of probably a lose if you're a
polar bearish animal with very thick fur
and you're white and you're kind of
trying to hang out in the tropics that's
probably not going to happen
um it's uh just as um so there's some
differentiation of that type but the
question of why are they quite the
number of species that there are there
isn't a good theory for that we don't
know
um it's it's a um and i think that that
that kind of um
uh
that there's sort of a the thing to
realize is
as
as you change the genome of the species
the genome is like a program
and there are a very infinite number of
possible programs and there's great
diversity and the kinds of organisms you
could make i mean imagine you know
people sometimes in science fiction
movies have had the kind of the the uh
the genetics hacker who's created these
weird creatures that you know open doors
for them or whatever else it is um and
uh that hasn't really been a real thing
yet
um of being able and perhaps it's a good
thing it hasn't been a real thing
because there are all kinds of problems
that could arise from it but um of being
able to have sort of special purpose
organisms large organisms created to
achieve a particular purpose that's been
done lots
in microorganisms and bacteria
many drugs for example are manufactured
by having a bacterium whose genetic
program has been modified so that one of
the proteins one of the things it
produces is the drug you want like
insulin for example
that's a very common thing to use uh e
coli which are type of bacteria that
live in our guts and so on um and you
basically just have lots of e coli that
have been modified to not just do the
usual e coli thing but to also have
these these extra pieces of program that
makes something that's useful for us but
in terms of large-scale organisms we
don't know how to make an organism that
you know has a uh oh i don't know
i don't know
an organism that can act like a robotic
vacuum cleaner or something and go
around and
you know we have to make do with you
know the pets that we have
sort of observed will will do particular
kinds of things we don't get to make a
sort of programmed
uh you know a program mammal or
something that will go and uh and do all
the things a vacuum cleaner would do or
some such other thing we don't know how
to do that yet
um
presumably it's possible in principle
presumably there is a genetic program
which would make such an organism but we
don't know what it is
um and we don't have a good way of doing
sort of progressive design
to to get to that point
one might think just as evolution does
this very slow process of randomly
making a change seeing whether it works
out randomly making a change et cetera
et cetera et cetera that if we could
just sit down with a kind of computer
design program and just say let's just
start from scratch let's design our
genetics so that we get an organism that
has particular properties that that
would be a winning thing to do and one
day maybe it will be but it's very hard
it's a kind of a problem it's sort of a
computationally irreducible problem to
go from the genetic sequence to the
actual behavior of the organism now
people there's a whole field of
synthetic biology where people try to
design at the level typically
microorganisms try to design organisms
that will have particular properties
like you know a good example of one that
people tried it didn't work out very
well was uh you know a a bacterium-like
organism that makes gasoline
um you know it's like forget having you
know it's something you can
that didn't work out i think primarily
because uh you couldn't get the organism
to not get sort of killed off
by by the gasoline that it produced so
to speak but you know that's the type of
idea of can you just make an organism
that will be custom designed to have a
particular purpose
and you know there's it's not clear
where the boundaries are and it's
certainly not known how to go from
scratch to build an organism that has
you know particular that's some kind of
cute organism with you know uh
purple
wings and all kinds of other stuff
nobody knows how to do that stuff yet
i think this question of whether
there is a um
uh sort of the the sort of increasing
complexity and how that plays out with
evolution
so another thing to say
is that
the
what organisms are successful depends on
in large part on the environments in
which the organisms find themselves
and this is again the question of is the
most successful organism the sleek very
simple organism that's just knows how to
you know
turn everything into copies of itself
versus the very elaborate kind of swiss
army knife organism that says oh i found
myself in a glacier let me go and start
you know let me deploy my skis so to
speak i found myself in a you know in
the top of a tree let me let me deploy
my my wing system so to speak you know
something which has all these different
uh bells and whistles so to speak on the
organism that it can deploy for
different purposes for example you know
what is the winning case is it the kind
of the the very simple i mean people
talk about uh
in a slightly different context in the
context of nanotechnology of being able
to make uh kind of arbitrary molecules
not not um
not biology but one of the things that
was a concern at one time was if we
managed to figure out how to make
essentially self-replicating very small
scale molecules that those small tail
molecules would just replicate
everywhere and we'll turn the whole of
our planet into grey goo or something as
all those molecules just make copies of
the molecules forget about all these
complicated organisms the most
successful thing
in that theory of what might happen is
the gray goo and so that's what our
planet gets turned into
so it's it's just not clear what makes
for the most successful organism
now you can ask the question
given the environment
that and given sort of what changes
genetics can make
is there some kind of principle
about the environment is somehow very
coarse
compared to the details of what can
happen in the genetics
and does that have an implication
for sort of the types of things that the
genetics could ever achieve let me try
to explain that a little bit more
and it's something actually i've been
thinking about somewhat recently and i
don't really know the full story of it
but
uh you know with the genetics you could
achieve you could in principle make that
you know creature with purple wings and
uh a green tail and you know all kinds
of other features
um
but
it requires a very detailed careful
sort of uh
careful set up of the genetics of the
organism to get to that point
now you imagine the environment in which
the organism lives
and it has a fairly coarse way
of
affecting the success of the organism
like if the organism has big thick fur
and it's trying to live at the equator
bad news but it's not the case that you
know let's say the polar bears had oh i
don't know
uh that's a good example
um
that's perhaps not the best example let
me think i mean in a
let's say
a
a tree
let's say the leaves of trees i've
looked at those a bit um those are
interesting because nobody really knows
why they're the shapes they are
that is some leaves are very simple they
have just a very rounded shape some
leaves have the very serrated edges some
leaves like oak leaves have all these
sort of indentations and so on there are
all these names that have been given to
the shapes of leaves that actually come
from from antiquity they're very latin
type names like dentate which you know
it's like like teeth-like shaped and
the um of eight and they're all kinds of
names they're actually you can find them
even in the um in the books where people
were trying to describe uh you know pick
up these plants they will be good for
you type things um and they were
identifying these plants by saying the
shapes of their leaves but anyway there
are very elaborate shapes of leaves
nobody knows why
the leaves of different plants are the
shapes they are it doesn't seem to it's
like well it so happens an oak tree has
leaves of that shape it so happens that
a such-and-such tree has leaves of some
other shape
those are things that seem like they
don't seem to matter much in detail to
the organism there are some features of
leaves like i think plants that live in
the tropics they have a drip tip at the
end of their leaf so the moisture that's
formed on the leaf can drip off the end
of the leaf things like that
um but that's a case where the question
is does the environment
sort of does it control the plants well
enough to be able to say okay you have a
leaf that's this particular shape or is
the environment this much coarser
constraint on what's going on and within
those constraints the plants are sort of
moving around trying trying different
shapes
you know one thing i i looked at years
ago um is
uh the the shapes of mollusks and i
happen to realize i have a convenient
mollusk here here's a nice there we go
that's a um you know these mollusks grow
in this kind of spiral shape
and they um
uh
they have yeah it's that's that's the
non-virtual background type theory of
things um the
uh
and the question is
what different shapes
um
the uh you know what different shapes
can these molasses grow
and one of the things i was curious
about is if you imagine that they have a
definite sort of scheme for growing
where they just are making kind of a
spiral where the different sides of the
spiral grow at different rates
can all possible shapes be formed and
are they actually used by biology and
the answer is they are all used by
biology it's so it seems except for
rather trivial ones like ones where the
whole shell kind of closes up and
there's no space for the animal inside
so in any case i i think the
the answer to the original question
about does biological evolution lead to
complexity rather than simplicity as we
don't really know
and uh there are places where sort of
complexity seems to be winning out there
are other places the fact that you know
we're this complex organism and viruses
still have a big effect on us even
though they're very simple and some by
many measures relative to us um is kind
of a sign that we haven't sort of
complexity hasn't won so to speak
um and and so i think it's it's still
it's kind of an unsolved problem in the
theory in the sort of meta theory in a
sense of biological evolution it's one
that i think some ideas from our physics
project and some of the formalism of
multi-computation and so on may very
well have some really powerful things to
say about these questions of sort of
what are these trends these overall
trends in biological evolution why are
there different species why are there
the numbers of species that there are i
mean i'd like to be able to estimate you
know why are there 10 million species on
the earth you know given the the size of
the earth the age of the earth this and
that the other why are there 10 million
species we don't know
and uh uh that that's um that's
something i'd be curious to understand
um okay there's a bunch of biology
questions here so let me take a look at
these
um
okay this is uh
uh from parmenides this is an
interesting one
it says we should breathe extremophile
bacteria and algae to terraform planets
by slowly exposing toxic atmospheres
that's actually kind of an interesting
idea
so let me let me explain the pieces of
that um so extremophiles are critters
that live in in extreme environments
like the hydrothermal vents in the ocean
where there's very high temperatures
where there's lots of sulfur lots of
kinds of things that your average
organism like us like the bacteria in
our guts like other like the you know
ants and things like that they just die
in that those environments they'd be
they'd be cooked they'd be you know
killed by the sulfur all those kinds of
things but there are organisms that have
evolved to be able to exist in those
extreme environments and to be able to
be successful there in fact there are
theories that say that the original life
on earth might have been in those places
and it's only uh us kind of um uh less
uh you know we're the we're the kind of
um the weak creatures that managed to
survive even within in the non-in
non-extreme environment but the the real
things that started life were the
hardier things that could live in these
extreme environments not clear whether
that's true or not
so that the comment being made here is
about terraforming planets
so what is terraforming planet
so you know on the earth we have a nice
atmosphere with you know 20-ish percent
oxygen
78 ish uh nitrogen and so on we have um
uh
and we have um you know we have
we have an environment in which which is
good for us
now you know the environment probably
was the one that came first and we
evolved to be able to live happily in
that environment but now if we look at
mars and venus
um they both have atmospheres that
aren't very hospitable to us
you know mars has a very thin atmosphere
uh mostly carbon dioxide um uh and and
um uh
certainly uh you know we don't have
there's no breathable air there at the
at the kind of pressures that we would
need to to exist without a space suit
for mars
venus
has thick i think carbon dioxide and
maybe methane i'm not sure clouds uh i'm
trying to think i'm not sure what the
clouds are made of
i think there's a lot of carbon dioxide
there but venus is covered with a shroud
of clouds and the surface of venus is
like 350 degrees
centigrade i think uh it's extremely hot
um and so there's this question of could
you terraform could you turn these
planets into being like earth
by somehow using for example biological
organisms could you for example put some
kind of bacteria into the clouds of
venus and have them start uh
transforming just like on the earth
if we plant enough trees the trees will
the the the the trees turn carbon
dioxide into oxygen
they um
that's uh uh with you know with the with
using sunlight the photosynthesis turns
uh takes in carbon dioxide and produces
oxygen and so if we think there's too
much carbon dioxide in the atmosphere of
the earth it's kind of have more trees
is one of the solutions to that
and um but that's a place where you're
using biology to change the chemistry of
the atmosphere and so the idea would be
on venus have some kind of bacterium
that can kind of initially live in the
clouds on venus and and it'll start you
know maybe in the higher clouds it's not
it's not as hot and then it starts
transforming carbon dioxide into oxygen
and pretty soon you've changed the whole
atmosphere of venus
so that's that's kind of the concept
would it work
people have discussed that for years i
think the current belief is with the
technology we have now it won't work um
the the question that what amenities is
suggesting is that maybe we could
essentially evolve bacteria that would
be more successful in terraforming venus
and i think that's quite possibly the
case i mean this is a question of how
far can you push
life that's being constructed with rna
and dna and proteins and amino acids and
so on how far can you push it you
probably can't push it to 350 degrees um
it's probably really too hot probably
the fundamental chemistry is just
inappropriate for that but if you can
kind of work down from the top of the
clouds where it isn't as hot maybe
there's a way to sort of do the
equivalent of photosynthesis on venus
and transform all that carbon dioxide
into oxygen which will then have you
know not have these uh opaque clouds
which would then allow more heat to be
released cool the surface and pretty
soon you have a a a great tourist resort
on venus type thing
mars it's a little bit more complicated
um i think one suggestion about mars
that has a certain degree of craziness
to it is the ice caps of mars have have
uh uh
water ice in them and one idea is you
explode you know collections of hydrogen
bombs at the at the poles of mars and
you push up all that water that was was
in the ice you make it uh you vaporize
it and you put it up into the into the
atmosphere of mars and that that's the
way that you begin the process of
terraforming noise again i don't really
know if that would actually work
and it's sort of an interesting question
of sort of an ethics type question of
people worry a lot about sort of
defacing the earth and destroying
species on the earth
and if we are sure that
venus and mars are just rocks
nothing like life there then maybe we
feel okay about just sort of completely
whatever was there we obliterate it and
we come in and colonize type thing um we
might feel more squeamish if we felt
like well there might be some
microorganism there now if it's a
microorganism that's bizarrely different
from life we've ever seen that we
wouldn't even recognize it as life you
probably feel less squeamish it's kind
of a complicated sort of ethic scale of
what's involved in doing that and you
know
do we really feel okay about taking that
nearby planet and saying okay it's going
to be ours i i i kind of think like um
you know
personally i i think that's probably not
a difficult thing to decide but it's
something it's not it's not i think
totally self-advocate
um
okay there are all kinds of questions
here
uh
can bacteria be diabetic aaron asks wow
um
well let's think about that for a second
so
diabetes is a human disease there are
really two kinds type 1 type 2 diabetes
that
is they're both
associated with insulin which is an
enzyme that
is involved in metabolism
and
the uh
and in particular is involved in using
up using glucose
using um the uh
um
uh using the the um
uh
when when you eat food it has glucose in
it you're going to use that to
metabolize you're essentially going to
burn the glucose to make energy and
insulin is part of that process
and insulin is produced by the
pancreatic pancreas
gland in in us
by the beta cells in the in the pancreas
and
type 1 diabetes
uh
is a disease usually manifests in in
early life
where
uh the immune system starts attacking
the beta cells in pancreas which are the
things that produce insulin
and uh nobody knows why that happens
and although there's some genetics
that um uh
may increase the
likelihood of that happening but in any
case the immune system for whatever
reason goes and starts attacking cells
that are part of part of
you
which is bad and it will destroy the
beta cells in the pancreas which means
that you can't produce insulin yourself
anymore you need insulin to be able to
to metabolize things like glucose sugar
and so on and so you end up having to in
modern times i mean for the last hundred
years at least since insulin was
discovered you kind of inject or infuse
insulin into yourself at the appropriate
rate so that you can uh
so that you can go ahead and do your
usual
metabolism uh type 2 diabetes is
something that usually manifests at
later ages and it's uh
it's a thing where the um
the effect of of um
the you're producing insulin but it
doesn't have the effect that it would
usually have and so you have to kind of
give yourself more insulin to be able to
have the effect you would want the
insulin to have
so the question is
is is insulin
i believe that insulin is something that
has been used for like at least a
billion years in the history of life on
earth um and i think i don't know
whether i mean there are
there are things called search gs irt
genes if i remember correctly which are
some kind of thing related to insulin
and i'm afraid this is going beyond my
immediate memory um there's a there's a
quite a lot of belief about
the relationship of those genes to aging
and so on but um the i think the
question really is um is it the case
that you can
have a bacterium i i mentioned that you
can produce insulin in a bacterium you
can produce human insulin in a bacterium
by putting the genetic code for human
insulin into the code for a bacterium
and having it just okay i'm going to
produce proteins for myself well
actually i'm producing proteins
that correspond to the code i was given
that that corresponded human insulin
and i think the question is
is i don't know
i don't know exactly what the i don't
know i assume that there is an analog of
that in bacteria a similar kind of
enzyme and that it's possible for the
bacteria to not produce that enzyme in
which case or to be genetically modified
so they can't produce it in which case
they would have sort of the analog of
type 1 diabetes i think not sure
um
let's see question about from mikhail
about uh
um did craig venter indeed create
synthetic life or just change existing
species um
the
i think it's correct to say that
nobody has really produced
a a a living organism completely from
scratch
now
you know there are mechanisms like how
does the replication work how does the
you know rna come off the dna how does
the how does the ribosome work things
like that
um yeah in fact those those things we've
kind of gotten those from biological
evolution now how those get put together
to decide exactly what kinds of other
proteins the thing produces what
characteristics the organism will have
that's kind of the stuff of synthetic
biology potentially and people talk
about having sort of modular pieces of
of essentially genetics to be able to
fit them together to have a sort of a
construction kit to have organisms do
different kinds of things um i think
that's still
a kind of an early stage activity very
artisanal and not very it's not a sort
of industrial scale thing at this point
um i mean that again whenever you modify
the genes of a bacterium to like make
human insulin or something you're doing
something a bit like that you're you're
modifying the sort of the code of an
organism for a particular purpose but i
think the idea of let's just start from
scratch
um that's that's not a thing that's been
possible yet i mean if you're going to
start from scratch maybe there's a
better mechanism than the ribosomes that
walk down rna strands making proteins
you know they're a great big molecule
that has you know this all this sort of
complexity in it that sort of you know
read one thing add these pieces from
from the environment to make the next
step in the in the amino acid and so on
have the thing peel off all those kinds
of things it's kind of it's kind of neat
it's a pretty big molecule and um uh you
know you might imagine that some
engineer could come along and say i've
got a better way to do this actually
there's a really tiny molecule that will
succeed in in achieving the same purpose
but that's not something we've we've
done yet or know how to do
um
the uh
uh so that's the primary so-called
genetic engineering
is um uh is all about modifying existing
uh tends to be about modifying existing
organisms typically bacteria um for
these purposes now the application of
that to humans
is some uh
so-called gene therapy
um
and so okay so in humans
normally we have our genetic sequence
and it's six billion base pairs long and
we're born with it and every every cell
in our body has that same six billion
base pair sequence in it now there are
things called retroviruses that can go
and basically write back data
into the into the g into our genome so
you know it's one of the if you sort of
catch a retrovirus it can modify it can
actually go and rate it some of its
genetics back into our genome in fact if
we look at our genomes today
there are lots of pieces of our genome
that were undoubtedly added by
retroviruses in the past that were then
passed down
from from one uh
from one organism to another and so
that's a thing that can happen if you if
you can get to an organism and have a
retrovirus change its genetics then it
will really have changed the genetics
and it will pass down those genetics to
its progeny and so on
so one of the things that happens is it
will also pass it down to new cells that
are created within that same organism
and so for example there are diseases
where
there it's known that those diseases are
the result of of particular genetic
modifications in in human genome and if
you can just go and essentially edit
those modifications um then you can uh
then you can change that now one of the
big things that's happened in the last
10 years is this some
idea of gene editing this crispr cast 9
mechanism
this is the thing that originally came
from uh let's see if i get the history
right it came from viruses that infect
bacteria and it was kind of a clever use
of some mechanisms that existed in
nature but the end result is that you
can essentially make your own retrovirus
and you can essentially specify a
genetic sequence
and say
okay here's more or less how it works uh
on the genome there's lots of atcg
there's a big sort of random looking
sequence of those things
any given sequence more than about i
don't know eight or nine letters long
the chances are that's only going to
occur once or maybe no times at all
let's say you have a length 10 sequence
of a's and g's and g's and c's and so on
the chances are a random such sequence
will just never occur in the human
genome
but
many length 10 sequences let's say do
occur
and so if you have some molecules just
sort of floating around and it's kind of
you know checking out whether a
particular sequence that might exist on
that molecule matches a sequence that's
on the human genome then there's
probably a unique place where that
length 10 sequence matches
so what happens in gene editing is that
you are basically you you put the
payload that you want to deliver to the
genome sort of in between something
which essentially is matching flanking
sequences and then you say okay i'm
going to have this length 10 sequence on
the left length 10 sequence on the right
let's say i'm not sure what the typical
lengths actually are but let's say
length 10. you're going to say float
around the genome you know float around
find places where that length tension
matches okay that length 10 sequence is
matching in
i don't know some uh part of the genome
that produces some
uh
uh some
some some protein that's relevant for
the human retina let's say
um then
you um and then what will happen is the
thing will lock on in that place
and this mechanism this gene editing
mechanism will basically edit out the
piece of the genome that's in between
those flanking sequences and put in its
own payload so that it actually modifies
the genome of the organism and and
that's that's a potential approach to
treat some diseases um it's there's been
a complicated history in trials of that
kind of thing sometimes then some some
things that have gone wrong some things
that have gone right et cetera et cetera
et cetera um i mean it's it's some
uh the um uh so so
that um
that's the that's kind of the the way
that you potentially insert yourself
into
into some of the genomes of an organism
now you know people talk about so when
one of the ideas was
you know diseases like malaria a big
deal particularly in places like africa
and there was sort of this idea
malaria is carried by
by mosquitoes and if you can modify the
mosquitoes
to
not i'm trying to remember the details
of this but but you can i don't think
you're actually killing off the
mosquitoes i think you're just modifying
them so they can't carry the malaria
parasite or some such other thing um but
any case the the um
uh the the idea
was is
that with this gene editing thing you
could potentially uh introduce into the
mosquito population a modified genome
and that modified genome could somehow
be more successful than all the other
genetics of the mosquitoes and you would
essentially drive
that gene genetic modification into the
mosquito population thereby uh basically
changing all mosquitoes to not be able
to carry malaria for example okay this
is in the category of you know it's a
science idea and the it's in the what
could possibly go wrong category of of
um uh you know by the time you let out
loose this thing that is just going and
and and modifying uh kind of the um
the uh uh sort of not only modifying one
organism but modifying all of its child
organisms it's there
that's a little bit of a scary thing to
do and and many things could potentially
go wrong um so it hasn't to my knowledge
been done yet um and uh
but that's the kind of thing that
becomes possible with gene editing
let's see
uh
rbs comments maybe there is many species
on earth as there are different cellular
automaton rules that exhibit dna
patterns of mechanical structure of an
organism i think there are
you know this is the question of of you
know when you see people
drawing pictures of possible aliens
and uh sometimes there's a there's a
lovely book i have of somebody collected
kind of all the different renderings of
different kinds of aliens i have to say
that many of them are surprisingly
unimaginative they're basically a plant
with an animal head or you know other
things that look very much like just
sort of composites of terrestrial
organisms but there are some more
imaginative things as well and i have to
believe that that the full the
programmability
of biology is vastly greater than what's
actually been achieved um in in
biological organisms i mean the example
of molasses shells where the different
sort of growth rates
have been filled out yes that's a case
where it's been filled out but i think
if we look at the vast space of possible
organisms conceivable organisms we have
explored a just absolutely tiny region
of that space it's an interesting
question
whether
uh
sort of to what extent
you know how unusual is the stuff out
there in that space we know a little bit
about that because we can do an
analogous thing with programs
particularly these things called
cellular automata that i've spent lots
of time studying we just have a line of
cells and each cell updates its color
according to the colors of its neighbors
according to some fixed rule
and as you change the rule you'll get
different patterns and those patterns
often look rather lifelike and have all
kinds of things that you'd say oh that
must have been made by something
biological um no it's really made by
this very simple rule and there's sort
of a question of how diverse
is the possible behavior of those things
like cellular automata and how how much
if you saw those different pictures how
much would you identify it as oh those
are you know let's say in the tree of
life we have plants we have animals we
have archaeo bacteria or whatever their
care we have you know mammals we have
birds we have fish we have whatever else
those are sort of big clumps of stuff
and we could identify long before
anybody knew anything about genetics we
could say that's a fish that's a bird
they were morphologically they're
structurally different and so we can ask
for cellular automata can you
sort of put them in these buckets that
are like the fish versus birds bucket
and so on
many years ago i discovered that there
were at least at the simplest level
there are basically four classes of
behavior you see that are sort of the
very top level uh kind of types of
behavior a little bit like solids
liquids gases for materials there's
similar kinds of different types of
behavior for different rules of cellular
automata but it's an interesting
question and one actually should be
looked at again now um whether there's a
kind of a sort of a way of looking at
sort of speciation in cellular automata
where you'd say it's not exactly the
same pattern but it's a pattern of the
same type as this other one here it's
like it's another bird as opposed to
going all the way over here that it's a
fish um and so that question of sort of
what that space looks like and how
speciated it is it's an interesting
question and i i don't think we know i i
could say for certain we don't know the
answer to how that works um and that
might be an analogy for what happens in
in biology and maybe that kind of
thinking could get one to the the way of
estimating um
in um uh
uh you know in um
the number of species
um
so
comment here from riff the fact you can
edit genes makes me think so much can be
done to cure disorders and diseases yes
everybody thinks that i mean this is a
great discovery of the last 10 years
that could have probably been made a lot
earlier um but um
uh was was really a very wonderful
biological discovery um and it's really
a kind of a sort of a
it's like engineering gradually
discovers sort of oh there's this method
for doing this thing this is such a
discovery in biology um and uh yeah i
think it's it's a very much uh something
that one imagines that it will be
possible to edit genomes
to uh
to change those i mean you know the the
a slightly different approach that's
another kind of innovative thing is the
is the mrna
vaccines
for for um this virus
which have the feature that you're
basically injecting a little piece of
sort of active genetic material that
goes into cells and starts producing
proteins it's not something where you
say here's this finished goods here's
this finished thing the body should
react to it by producing antibodies
whatever else it's rather here's the
seed that will now grow
actual proteins inside cells
seems to be going okay um you know
not
that was something that had been being
developed for many years particularly as
a cancer uh vaccine approach because
cancers tend to have very different
genetics they have all kinds of
scrambled genetics in them and the
concept would be that given a particular
cancer in a particular person you would
custom make kind of a piece of mrna that
would be sort of a seed to produce
proteins that would cause the immune
system to react to those proteins and
attack the cancer
and that was something that people had
had worked on for a long time but nobody
quite knew how to deliver mrnas to cells
and then
in this in this pandemic with the
development of mrna vaccines uh suddenly
this whole lipid nanoparticle approach
of encapsulating in sort of a
microscopic version of a biological cell
you're encapsulating this mrna to get it
inside your biological cells where it
can kind of go to work and start
producing proteins that was very much
accelerated by the by the desire to have
vaccines uh produced quickly and so that
will no doubt have many consequences for
the medicine in the years to come as
well as will gene editing although there
are lots of details of that and lots of
things where you know things have gone
wrong and one has to worry about
different kinds of effects you know one
feature of biology is you know you think
you're doing one thing but there's
something over here on the side that you
know a typical example is you think
you're making a drug that is going to
have some effect on some particular kind
of tissue in your body
but actually the shape of that drug
binds a little bit to some completely
different tissue that does something
completely different or maybe in some
people because their version of the
molecules in that tissue are slightly
differently shaped it binds to theirs
but not to other peoples and so it's
it's it's always very difficult to know
in reality you know what will happen
with one of these theoretically good
idea kind of medical approaches and it
doesn't it doesn't help that of us 8
billion humans or whatever uh you know
we're all different
and you know you can say well i tested
this on 100 humans a thousand humans
whatever but it may turn out that the 10
000th human it has some some terribly
bad effect and that was extremely hard
to predict because it just was an effect
that came about because of some
particular genetic feature of that
particular organ of that particular
human that didn't really affect them in
their ordinary you know life but in the
case of this particular drug it bound to
some protein in some way that wasn't
expected and bad things happen so it's
very hard to to figure out and that's
sort of the theory of
of um
clinical trials and testing and so on
but you can never do it perfectly and it
becomes there are many complexities when
you particularly if you try and make
drugs that are very customized to a
particular individual
well then you really can't do that kind
of broad testing because you made
something specific to that individual
and testing it on a thousand people who
are all different from that individual
doesn't really help you
um okay one may be one last comment or
question here
um uh
happy comments what if the malaria
parasite has some kind of function in
biological systems that we're completely
unaware of this is the kind of thing
they say that they're always wondering
about yeah well that's what happens
that's that's why biology and things
like that are really hard because there
are there are just so often these kind
of unintended consequences unintended
effects
i mean
that
there's a lot of even fairly fundamental
questions in biology but we don't really
know why something happens the way it
happens and it's like oh you can just
you know take out that
that piece of some tissue in a human oh
whoops we didn't realize that had some
little film thin you know
in a skin type thing that we just cut
through and and that caused these
problems um you know it's it's there's
it's
there's a lot of of unknown unknown so
to speak where we just don't really
understand how all the biology works
even if we did it's full of this sort of
computational irreducibility phenomenon
of even if we know kind of how what the
setup is that doesn't mean we're able to
uh to figure out sort of what the
consequences will be and yes this is the
thing that uh sort of regularly happens
when people say
let's just
uh
oh i don't know what's a good example
um
there have been so many of them i and i
don't know them in detail but there are
cases where people say let's kill off
the population of some kind of animal
that we don't like around here and then
you pretty soon you discover that
animals you did like
uh start dying off because they depended
on eating the animals you didn't like
for example i think mosquitoes for
example i think are food for dragonflies
so i think by the time you if you kill
off all the mosquitoes for example the
dragonflies won't have any food um and
then if the dragonflies don't have food
i don't really know what consequence
that has dragonflies have been around a
long time they were around in the
carboniferous period um and uh you know
i i don't know exactly how dragonflies
fit into the ecosystem uh for for the
world but that's the exactly the type of
thing you know you say we don't like
this kind of organism let's get rid of
that one oh whoops
we just destroyed something at a
different place in this kind of web of
interdependent organisms
now you know does that mean you should
do nothing
no it doesn't mean you should do nothing
but it's always tricky and i think
assuming that you know you know you know
one effect and you say yes this is going
to be the main effect we don't like
about the the mosquitoes for example
let's just kill them off um you know
typically things don't work as simply as
that there's a more complicated set of
independences and so on and i don't know
quite what the right strategy is it's
probably you try doing some things you
see what happens you do another thing
see what happens and you kind of
gradually uh sort of ease into what's
going on rather than saying you know
we'll do just this or that i mean it's
like for example one of the things that
similar kind of issue
uh you know one of the potential
ways of getting carbon dioxide out of
the atmosphere you know there's a bunch
of carbon dioxide that's put into our
atmosphere by burning fossil fuels and
other kinds of things like that
um that you know one flies planes one
one has drives cars that uh you know uh
burn gasoline one has factories one has
all kinds of things that that uh you
know we want to do that put calm down
into the atmosphere and so one of the
questions is well can we do something
else that pulls carbon outside out of
the atmosphere and so there are a whole
bunch of of schemes for doing that but
one of them which people argue about
whether it will work or not is to seed
the southern ocean with iron
and in the in the oceans there are there
are plankton and algae and so on which
can ingest carbon dioxide and so the
idea would be well just make more of
those just make the oceans be more
teeming with critters that can ingest
from the outside and then you can solve
the problem of there being too much
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere um
and you know so will that work will that
not work people argue about this
i think there was a moment when somebody
just decided to go do it
go you know take a ship and just stop
dumping iron i think that's the thing
that that helps these um these
microorganisms grow um and so on and
everybody said no no you shouldn't do
that um and uh but but you know the
question of what the mechanism for if
that is really a good idea if that's
kind of like the oh we just do this and
then we don't have a problem with you
know the amount of carbon in the
atmosphere and so on it's um that would
be a win but but it's a hard decision to
make and uh uh these things you know if
you grow more algae does that mean you
kill off the fish does it you know what
what really happens difficult things to
figure out and i think one of the things
to realize is that the kind of simple
science answers are almost never correct
and this is a this is a consequence of
this very theoretical phenomenon of
computational irreducibility that i kind
of came up with in the 1980s um that uh
sort of the even though you may know the
rules by which the system operates
knowing what consequences they will have
is arbitrarily hard and that's something
that we see in practice particularly in
biological kinds of situations and it's
something where when we imagine a policy
when we imagine just saying oh you can
you know let's just do this
that's uh
you're kind of being you might say well
science proves that this works that's
usually a bad answer because there's
computational irreducibility which is a
thing of science that's kind of in the
back saying well actually there will be
unintended consequences and you can't
get rid of those it's a fundamental
feature that there will be these things
that you can't readily predict from the
beginning and so you have to kind of
adopt a a slightly uh
lower confidence
lower hubris
um kind of approach to to dealing with
the world um to take account of the fact
that there are things that science from
within itself is telling you you cannot
readily foresee
all right i think we should uh
wrap up here well thank you for
very interesting questions and um
uh
that was fun to chat about
and um
uh look forward to um
to chatting again next week
so i should wrap up go back to my day
job here um and uh actually i'm doing i
think my next
discussion is about basic science so i
get to do some basic science here um
anyway nice to chat with you all and uh